happy 500,000 thank you guys so much for
subscribing to my channel and for
joining me on this scientific adventure
you know if you got 500,000 people
together and we all held hands in a line
it would stretch from Sydney to
Melbourne or from San Francisco to San
Diego or from London to Inverness
oi what are you forming a line here for
you're gonna skid off this it right so I
suppose I should get down to answering
your questions go ahead hit me with your
best shot I understand that the sky is
blue due to Rayleigh scattering short
wavelengths gets scattered way more and
blue light dominates because it's so
short if that's the case why isn't the
sky violet okay here's the thing the sky
isn't really blue it's bluish white so
the sky is illuminated by the Sun and
the Sun emits all colors but not equally
the Sun doesn't emit that much red nor
does it emit that much violet most of
the light it emits is kind of in the
greeny part of the spectrum
now as you point out due to Rayleigh
scattering more of the shorter
wavelengths are scattered and that is
why the sky looks blue because it's
basically the sun's white spectrum
shifted a little bit towards the blue
this is the spectrum of the blue sky and
as you can see it's quite broad and in
fact there is a fair amount of violet
light in there but there's not as much
violet light as there is blue light
because the sunlight that we started
with had much more blue than it had
violet if I have a laptop on the
International Space Station with a hard
disk drive in it will the torque from
its spinning cause the laptop to spin as
well well by the law of conservation of
angular momentum yes the laptop should
spin I did a quick back of the envelope
calculation and I found that if you spun
up your hard disk from rest up to 5400
rpm then it would cause the laptop to
spin in the opposite direction at a rate
that would cause it to do about one
revolution every 17 seconds what would
happen if you poured liquid oxygen on a
fire
KABOOOM say you were able to pass the
event horizon of a black hole and come
back
what would coming back look like for the
person and for an observer well to an
outside observer it would look as though
you never came back at all and to the
person it would look as though you
didn't come back either because once you
past the event horizon that's it your
entire future lies within the black hole
and it will only be a matter of seconds
before you are in the singularity the
very core of this black hole and you are
no longer now if you could bring a
rocket pack with you and try to fight it
if you tried to accelerate away from the
black hole you would find that you
actually live for less time you might
see more space but your time would pass
more slowly and so you would end up in
the singularity sooner so I guess the
lesson is don't fight it if you want to
live longer just relax and go with it
you've met a lot of interesting people
on your adventures but is there someone
specific that you would love to meet I
would love to meet Bill Nye Neil
deGrasse Tyson Richard Dawkins and
President Obama as a non-scientist
inclusion I really like his book so if
you haven't read The Audacity of Hope
that's a good recommendation if all the
galaxies are constantly accelerating
away from each other will they ever
reach the speed of light or stop
accelerating all together so yeah all
the galaxies do seem to be accelerating
away from each other faster and faster
which makes this kind of a unique time
in the history of the earth because
right now we can still see that there
are hundreds of billions of galaxies but
sometime in the future due to the
expansion of the universe those galaxies
will be so far away and yes they will be
receding at faster than light speed and
then you might say well nothing can go
faster than light and it's kind of true
in that these galaxies won't be moving
through space at a speed faster than
light but the space in between us and
them will be expanding at a rate which
means that they will be moving relative
to us faster than light if that makes
any sense so they're like that they're
emitting we'll never be able to reach us
because
it'll never be able to make progress
through this expanding space it's kind
of interesting to think about what will
happen as that time approaches well the
light that is coming from those distant
galaxies travels across this expanding
space and so it becomes redshifted
cosmologically and eventually the
wavelength of this light will be so big
that its wavelength is the size of the
whole universe and that is impossible to
detect so at some point probably about
two trillion years in the future we will
only see our local cluster of galaxies
now the reason they haven't gone out to
infinity or very very far away is
because they're gravitationally bounded
to us so even though space is expanding
on a large scale the gravitational force
is enough to hold all of us together so
we will be in it for the long haul but
this still means that there's going to
be strange cosmology if we're still
around trillions of years from now if we
tried to look out we would see a very
different universe the universe which is
much emptier than the one we see today
so we live at a unique point in space
time we should appreciate that is there
such a thing as randomness in the
universe and if so isn't that
contradictory to science yes I think
there is randomness in the universe and
no I do not think this contradicts
science though perhaps you're thinking
along the lines of Albert Einstein when
he said God does not play dice he wasn't
happy when in quantum mechanics it
seemed as though some events have
probabilistic outcomes I mean he thought
that there were some hidden variables
there and we just didn't know what was
determining the outcome so we thought it
was probabilistic but all experiments
seem to show up to this point anyway
that there are some things which are
randomly determined they are
probabilistic in their nature for
example you can get quantum random
number generators and even the FBI and
CIA can't seem to find any pattern in
those numbers so they really truly do
seem to be random so yes it seems from
all the experimental evidence that
randomness is a fundamental part of our
universe albeit mostly on the quantum
scale what shape is the universe and
could light from our Sun go around the
universe and
come back and hit the other side of the
shape of the universe seems to be flat
which means there is no large-scale
curvature of space-time and the supposed
reason for this is inflation this idea
that very very very shortly after the
Big Bang the whole universe just started
accelerating an incredibly fast rate so
even if it was kind of Wiggly or warped
or curved around on itself before
inflation after inflation it basically
would have been flattened out just like
blowing up a balloon that side is going
to become you know more or less flat so
within the limits of our observational
capabilities for these days we think
that the universe is flat so if you go
out in one direction you probably
shouldn't return the way you came so
know the universe does not appear to be
closed and you probably never see the
light coming up behind you hey man I
have one fantastic topic for you to make
a video about but I need your response
you want to do it otherwise I contact
Vsauce hey Michael you want this one or
shall I take it no no no go ahead dare
take it so we are really reaching the
atomic size but not in some exotic
laboratory device in every device you
have in your computer on your mobile
phone how many transistors are on a chip
now not a billion depending what you buy